keep this interactive so don't let me
roll past anything that you find
interesting or that you want to be
argumentative about and also let me say
that this talk is maybe a bit unusual in
that I'm not primarily here to tell you
stuff but I'm primarily here to find out
stuff either from you or from people
that you know so I'm I'm normally at the
University of Colorado and visiting the
this area for about six months and one
of my missions here is to understand the
topic of this talk taking advantage of
the fact this is a world center of
research in this kind of thing so
perhaps some of you work on this kind of
thing or maybe even if you don't you
have ideas about it I'd love to hear
about and then some of you will have a
sister-in-law who is somebody who works
in this area and I'd love to be in touch
with them well I'll say more about some
of these possible connections later on
so just adding to that background so the
particular role I'm playing here is
connected with something called the
Coleman Institute for cognitive
disabilities it's been running for close
to 20 years and in Colorado the mission
is described there to really explore how
technology can as you just heard really
enhance what people are are able to do
and one of the ways the Institute works
on this is to inform its stakeholders
who are many and diverse about
developments that might be consequential
for them so you'll see that the
stakeholders include people with
disabilities themselves and then a bunch
of other kinds of people including
government leaders policy makers people
who make funding decisions and that kind
of thing so so part of our role is to
help people like that understand what
they should be thinking about in this in
this space so machine learning is
something we we all hear about many
advances in so the question naturally
arises what's going on there that we
want to know about and and maybe even
more than that what's going to happen
that we want to know about so here's
what I want to do so I want to take you
through some
the things that people with cognitive
disabilities would like to do and of
course I'm selecting ones where there's
maybe some prima facie case that machine
learning might play some role there and
then you get into that so what what
might machine learning do in some of
these situations what are some of the
limitations at least today that that
might keep us from doing all the things
we wouldn't want to do and then some
maybe slightly miscellaneous points but
which I think tie in so a lot of these
systems are going to be providing
assistance in one way or another and and
some of those ways of providing
assistance are kind of interesting in
themselves and so we want to talk about
that and then there are some risks of
course to think about and then I hope
we'll have some time for for discussion
so I'll start with with this so we all
know that real soon now this is what
automobiles will look like and and the
reason I'm mentioning this is you might
not have expected this to come up in a
talk about cognitive disabilities but in
fact for people with disabilities
generally the likely imminent advent of
autonomous transportation on a wide
scale is is a really really big deal so
I worked as an advisor to a person named
Charlie lakyn when he was director of
the National Institute of on disability
and rehabilitation research a disability
research funding agency and and Charlie
would say that whenever people with
disabilities are surveyed about the
challenges they face in life that quite
commonly the top of that challenge list
is transportation and then the
disability field as represented by
Charlie and many others would sort of
not really do anything about that
because there wasn't much they could do
outside say urban areas where certain
kinds of supports can be can be offered
well autonomous vehicles are going to be
great so many people with cognitive
disabilities can't drive and and this is
this is hugely limiting for them and
another theme that won't be surprising I
think to anybody if you are a person
with a cognitive disability one of the
things you're most concerned about is
your independence and your
Danah me so you're used to being in a
very dependent situation and people and
generally hate that for very good reason
so this is a big deal and of course this
is heavily dependent on advanced as a
machine learning so this is a great
thing that's that's going to happen so
that's an example of something oh there
are lots you know not being able to read
road signs in some cases would be would
be an issue you actually you'll see more
about this when we talk about some other
cases but you know having poor judgment
finding it slow yeah being slow to make
decisions and choices there's a whole
range of things so it's very common but
not everybody of course and of course
well I'm not really taking time to get
into this but but the space to call it
that of cognitive limitations or
cognitive disabilities is extremely
diverse so there are plenty of people
with cognitive impairments of one kind
or another who can drive fine but there
are many people who can't now the focus
here is is cognitive but but the lovely
weird comorbidity comes up and that is
important so it happens that if you if
you pick a person with a cognitive
disability at random it's quite likely
that he or she will also have other
issues some of which could be perceptual
but mostly I'm gonna be focusing on the
cognitive side of things in part because
if I need any excuse for that
you know soraka's been way more
attention in particular to supporting
people with visual limitations and then
maybe next might be you know sort of
deafness and hard-of-hearing and and
then mobility comes in there somewhere
motor stuff and and until pretty
recently cognitive disability was hardly
anywhere especially when people were
considering what might be done
technically so the focus here is
cognitive so here's a local example and
some of you may may know about this so
this is a stanford project and this is
an illustration of something that's
happening now using machine learning to
deliver some kind of benefit
these are army surplus Google glass
things that are being used as I
understand it and so you wear the Google
glass and there's an app that drives it
and the app is capable of estimating the
emotional state of the person that the
glasses are looking at and and this is
important for for some kids with autism
for whom judging people's emotional
state is an aspect of their general
difficulty with social interaction so
what this thing will do is is say well
it looks like the person you're talking
to right now is happy
another interesting angle on this is
that that it's easy to appreciate
classifying emotions from expressions is
not very easy and so it's worthwhile in
this application to actually do special
training on a per participant basis with
people that they're likely to interact
with so family members or a teacher for
example so so in deployment what they
will try to do here is is augment the
sort of general background training that
the system has in it about you know
people generally with making it
particularly good at picking up the
expressions of the people you're most
likely to be talking with I just learned
today literally that is it interesting
and to be unexpected limitation of this
that this is great for some kids but
there are a lot of other kids for whom
functionally this would be great but it
doesn't work at all anybody want to
guess why not nope they don't want to
wear the headset they won't wear it so
it that's an interesting kind of
crossover excuse me yeah that's right so
this this is say this is a pretty common
part of autism but another common part
of autism is extreme aversion of certain
kinds of being touched and and
unfortunately that interacts badly here
so the actually we were discussing that
this seems like it's it makes the
problem bit tougher but but there is the
possibility of further developing the
technology to deal with this issue
a person who doesn't want to wear
anything on his or her head might be
willing to wear something if it was
built into their clothing and the reason
this complicates the learning problem is
that this is greatly aided by the fact
that having about it in the glasses
provides you like a really good front on
image of the face and that would be
tougher if you had to do it from say a
chest mounted camera but but
nevertheless so this is this is an
example intended as like with the
autonomous vehicle thing to say well
there's already things happening that
you know are gonna do good here so now
we can move to other things that it
would be great to be able to do that or
not it's it's not so clear what's going
on
so Medicaid Waiver is a is a jargon term
for a service that's offered as part of
the Medicaid the federal Medicaid system
so every state has a sort of portfolio
of these services called waivers and and
the genius of our federal system is
they're all kind of different so there
was a project which sadly is no longer
in operation which took the all the
descriptions of these waivers for all
the 50 states and translated them into a
more comprehensible forum and I'll give
you an illustration in a moment but
here's kind of the raw form of it so
perhaps you can recognize this as you
know some sort of bureaucrat ease or
whatever and if you're thinking well
this is a service that's aimed at people
for whom cognitive processing is not a
strength maybe it's easy to see that
having that translated into something
like this form is really a good thing so
this was done by a human editorial
process that included a self-advocate at
a friend of mine actually named Nancy
Ward is a very skilled editor in this
role so the way this worked was that
that people who didn't have cognitive
disabilities would kind of do their best
to come up with what they thought was a
more comprehensible description of this
thing and Nancy would more or less read
this and say so what is it that this is
we're really trying to say here and then
the editors would say what that was do
you say well why don't we just say that
and so so the result is is that so I
think you can recognize that
it's that statement is not only a lot
shorter but it's a lot easier to tell
what it actually what it actually means
and I just said that this service is no
longer being operated because it's
expensive it has to be maintained and
all that kind of thing so if we could
automate this kind of process this would
be really great and of course this is
just one of indefinitely many examples
of this kind so so making text more
comprehensible is something we'd really
like to be able to do a better job and
we'll say more about all of these things
in a bit okay so here's a different kind
of example and and the background here
is this is an example I owe to a person
named Paul nish Minh who works for an
organization called source America so
source America is a federally charted
nonprofit that supports a federal job
set-aside program so our legislators
acting on our behalf recognized that
there are certain jobs that are pretty
common in the aggregate across the whole
federal system that are not very
demanding cognitively and so they've
arranged that there's a hiring
preference for these jobs for people who
have serious cognitive limitations and
one category of such jobs is is some
groundskeeping jobs so you can imagine
somebody who's a groundskeeper at a VA
hospital or an army base or whatever and
and paul is a it was a extremely capable
and ingenious person and acts as a kind
of national troubleshooter in this world
so so somebody's placed in one of these
jobs and then Paul gets called in if if
contrary to expectation the person
actually had trouble doing whatever it
is and so he has a lot of interesting
examples and here's one of them so so
one of his clients was on there riding
mower mowing the grass at some federal
installation and and they came upon a
patch of shrubbery and in the shrubbery
was a wasp's nest so they stopped their
mower and one got the gasoline for their
mower and poured the gasoline on the
wasp nest and set it on fire and in the
process set the nearby building on fire
so fortunately the fire was detected
quickly so it wasn't a true catastrophe
but this is an illustration actually if
you think back to the question about
driving
so here's a person where you could say
well you know they just don't have good
judgment okay so they're looking at this
and saying wasp you know this is a
problem I want to do something about it
well that's okay it's perfectly
reasonable but then they're not able to
make a good decision about what actions
are reasonable and safe and prudent to
take in response to that problem so
we'll be thinking about you know what
could we imagine that might be done to
help in a situation like this could we
imagine some form of artificial agent
that could monitor what's going on in
the situation recognize this kind of
thing and again we'll come back to this
so this is actually two tasks these
these come from another friend of mine
whom I won't name she's an attorney
actually employed in the federal
government and she was employed in the
federal government but in her perfectly
ordinary white-collar work force a
workplace she suffered a freak fall and
hit her head against some kind of a
corner and and sustained a very serious
brain injury this was several years ago
and you know she's all things considered
she's doing remarkably well but but she
would definitely say there are very many
things that she used to be able to do
that she simply can't do anymore
several years after sustaining this this
injury and this is say nothing about
sleep interference and a whole host of
whole host of other things well so she
learned as maybe some of you know that
there services from which one can hire
remote human assistants so the market
that these agencies serve is for
instance somebody who's I don't know a
high-level freelance designer travels
around a lot from job to job and lacks a
kind of a stable home base with an
ordinary kind of you know resident
administrative assistant so the service
allows such a person to contract with
someone in in the case of my friend it's
in Mumbai and this person in Mumbai
assists you over the phone and by email
and all that kind of thing
in the ordinary case a common example
would be making travel arrangements say
but I'm illustrating here two of the
things that that my friend had her
assistant do so one was helping her
manager her many prescriptions so I've
certainly had the experience may you
maybe you have as well that you know
I've got a prescription and I do what I
think I needed to do and then I go to
the pharmacy and lo and behold the
prescription isn't ready for me and so I
have to cool my heels or come back later
or whatever well for my friend that
never happens okay because her assistant
working from Mumbai would place the
necessary phone calls and and let my
friend know okay this prescription is
actually ready for you to pick it up you
can go and do that the gifts represent
another thing so my friend is a very
generous person with a wide circle of
friends to whom she often gives gifts
and she found that she couldn't keep
track of who she had given what and so
one of the things she charged her remote
assistant in Mumbai to do was to manage
the state for her so to avoid the
embarrassment of giving somebody a
coffee machine for this birthday with
our coffee maker for this birthday when
you'd already given them a coffeemaker
for their last birthday now I've talked
with her recently she's actually no
longer employing her remote personal
assistant reason I'm stressing the
remoteness is probably obvious to you
the interface presented by a remote
human assistant is pretty narrow and so
that kind of makes certain things about
all this potentially quite easy for a
for a robot or artificial assistant
anyway in talking with my friend she is
emphatic she would far rather have an
artificial assist of doing these things
than her remote assistant even though
she never had a see the remote assistant
and this relates to something I alluded
to earlier
she hates any feeling of dependence on
another person this this is just like
salt in the wounds it's bad enough not
to be able to do something but it's even
worse if the people that are around you
or somehow
where that you can't do them even if in
this case this is a hired person even so
she found that difficult than
distasteful and that's part of the
reason she's not doing anymore I'm not
completely clear actually why she
stopped doing it but that's an element
of it but anyway as I was talking with
her about this talk actually she was
saying boy I would just love love it if
I could have an artificial agent that
would do these things she was another of
these situations this one comes from a
from a literature that's generated by
parents of whose children have cognitive
impairments and they write books about
kind of what that was like and
challenges that they and their children
face so here's here's one so the young
man living at home and one afternoon
he's very excited because one of his
friends is having a birthday party and
so the circle of friends are all going
to the movies very much anticipated
event in due course the son comes home
from the movies all angry upset really
bent out of shape and the mother of
course is really distressed it says well
Tom you know you were you were so much
looking forward to Julie's birthday you
know what happened so he explains so the
story is that they all get to the movie
theater and julie surprises all of them
by saying my treat i'm buying the movie
tickets great they hadn't expected that
terrific as they're going into the movie
they passed the popcorn stand and tom
says so Julie are you buying popcorn for
us and Julie says no I'm not going to do
that and Tom gets really angry and
frustrated he thinks Julie should have
bought the popcorn he's really angry
about it so the mother says well you
know Tom you had the money that you had
with you to buy your ticket you you
could have popped the popcorn and Tom
says oh yeah I could have so two things
about that so first on in the event Tom
couldn't recruit that knowledge about
the fact that he had the money and he
could have bought the popcorn and he
could have resolved the issue that way
so so that's you could say kind of his
issue but the further thing is note that
when the mother pointed that out it was
perfectly clear to him
so it's not like he somehow didn't
understand the nature of money or any of
those things he's capable of
understanding all of it
he couldn't recruit the necessary
knowledge as I think any of us would
have so again we can ask could Tom have
had some sort of agent accompanying him
that that could have helpfully
intervened in that situation and say
well Tom you know you seem to be getting
pretty upset here but I having knowledge
and of course this is where the rub lies
and I'll try to do this the challenge
was to try to do this the agent knows
that Tom had the money and blah blah
blah blah tall order but anyway we'll
we'll be talking more about this kind of
thing okay
so what are we talking about here so a
few things we'd like to be able to do
make text more comprehensible recognize
when there's some kind of a deviation
from typical or appropriate behavior and
then provide some sort of assistance in
the context of ordinary day to day kind
of transactions so tech simplification a
lot going on here some of you may know
so this is just a kind of a splash of
things so iBM has an offshoot of their
Watson technology has something called
the Content clarifier and you can see
there's a bunch of things oh I'm really
interested so Salesforce sees part of
their bread buttered by the idea of
being able to provide automatic
summarization which is an element of
simplification to help their their
clients so they I guess feel that their
clients often find that they've got too
much to read and so the notion for them
of having stuff condensed is is useful
so this is all this is all progress but
I think one can argue that these things
you know sort of generic summarization
just kind of making things short or if
just often done by just kind of
selecting what content retain throwing
away other stuff and then simplification
which could include vocabulary reduction
or or miss trick
the syntax that these things are are
progressive in this context but they're
only they're only part of the solution
and and and the reason is or part of the
the situation is that some what you want
to do depends on what you think the
reader knows so you have to have some
representation of that and actually in
some cases in order to make something
intelligible you have to add content
because whoever wrote the passage
assumed the reader knew something rather
and the reader doesn't know that and so
you have to kind of add it and I think
we can illustrate some of this by
looking back at that example I gave
earlier so I've kind of highlighted just
some of the text there so if we look at
certainly part of the key of the
translated presentation it refers to
help with day to day activities which is
you know something which is a pretty
meaningful sort of notion and if you
look at the original passage there's
really nothing that obviously says that
anywhere so I've highlighted a couple of
things that you could say are sort of
the basis of that you know these
references to functional this and
function all that but notice this isn't
just a matter of replacing functional so
nobody would say out of context that
functional meant day to day or whatever
so this translation makes sense on the
basis that the entity that created it
people in this case actually knew
something about the situation being
described and they knew well okay in
this setting what they mean by
functional things has to do with support
for things people have to do day to day
so this is this is so far beyond the
reach of what people seem to be able to
do with with sex simplification ago say
more about that again so how about
detecting unusual behavior so this is
actually work that's some years old now
so Tomas Yi's oh these days is over at
Google when he was at MIT did what I'm
showing here so they they created a
surveillance camera arrangement where
you could just kind of set it up
anywhere and turn it on and it would run
and munch what it was seeing and it
would build a model
of the visual dynamics that it saw
happening out there so in this example
they've had it watching a parking lot
and on the Left what you see is a
graphical depiction graphical depiction
of the dominant clusters of trajectories
which are differentiated by location
velocity and also size so the thing is
absolutely no understanding of anything
so it doesn't know what a car is and it
doesn't know what a people or a person
is but it does know that some things are
big and some things are small and it's
able to separate the trajectories of big
things and small things which we know is
the difference between cars and people
and then what's showing on the right
there is that after some time of
digesting all of this it's able to flag
episodes that fall outside the structure
of these clusters so it's not too easy
to interpret those images but but one of
them is a person who's found to be
following a trajectory that people don't
ordinarily take and another case there's
a car that goes somewhere where cars
don't ordinarily go and it actually
involves backing up which cars don't
ordinarily do in that in that situation
so so this is progress and actually I
haven't really developed this aspect of
the topic but there are situations which
I think something very close to this if
not literally this could be helpful so
to say a little something about that so
some people with cognitive disabilities
get jobs that involve certain kinds of
assembly operations or or packing
operations so taking elements and
putting them into containers for
shipment and the common fact there is
that people can work very well at these
kinds of jobs as long as everything's
going kind of the way it's supposed to
do but if there's some failure which
could be a defective part or failure of
a supply of a part or anything that
breaks up the routine people need help
and what's what's what's often that
sometimes done now is to instrument the
workplace with a lot of special sensors
to try to detect things
like a part not being available and as
you'll appreciate this is expensive to
do and kind of brittle you know if you
if you change something about the
workflow then you got to worry about
redeploying reconfiguring these sensors
and whatnot so it'd be very cool if
instead you could have one or more of
these surveillance cameras kind of
watching what's going on and and what
would you do if you detect something
anomalous well in these kind of settings
people have people called job coaches
who are there to kind of backstop things
but to make that work it's important
that the duty cycle of the job coach we
kept light so that he or she can be
doing other productive work you don't
want them having to sort of be watching
all the time what's going on so so this
technology could actually be quite
useful in that in that in that kind of
situation but in the gascan situation i
think we can see that we're looking for
something that's a step up from that so
I stressed that the surveillance camera
has no idea what the semantics of
anything it's seeing is and in the in
the wasp nest case we'd like it if we
could we'd like to be able to identify
that some behavior is is actually risky
or or or dangerous and you know an
aspect of that would be that you know
picking up the gasoline can isn't in
itself something the person shouldn't do
I mean they do need presumably to to
refuel the the mower so being able to
recognize that the particular thing
they're doing is risky not so easy and
you might be thinking and you'd be right
well maybe you could hope to detect
flame or something like that and maybe
you could say that under a wide range of
conditions flame isn't a good idea you
can I wasn't planning to yeah anyway
I'll just note that that and again it
can be useful to work out special cases
like detecting flame but at the same
time like we'd all realize that if we do
in a more general way that would be that
would be better we'd have a more robust
system so we can think about whether
that might be possible
okay so those everyday transactions
involve working within a context that
one has to understand and then another
thing is so you might be thinking so
take the keeping track of gifts you know
probably most people in this room could
could sort of script something that
would do that you know you could come up
with some app within the that interfaces
with Google sheets or something like
that to keep track of that but but
that's not really a starter here because
doing that and fall in the category of
things that my friend can't do is sort
of complicated so again our aspiration
would be to have a system that is more
like her human assistant so she didn't
have to direct her human assistant by by
writing some kind of script she could
just describe in the way one would the
activity of keeping track of of gifts
and the person acquired the ability to
do that so we can ask ourselves are we
able to develop artificial assistants
that have that oh and then another thing
which any of you thinking about machine
learning will be thinking about as well
I mean something that shows up all the
time is that we as system it's able to
do something but you know first you have
to give it a hundred thousand instances
of the things like what you want it to
deal with and again that's that's not
going to happen in a lot of the
situations we're happening here we're
dealing with here okay so so pulling
some of these things together and
there's a big question mark then again
I'd love to know what what you all think
or what people you can put me in touch
with think but it was sort of a
tentative as assessment I would make is
that these kinds of things I've just
been stressing are really kind of at the
frontier or beyond the frontier of what
we're able to do so
so take you know take natural language
processing well there's been a lot of
progress my impression is yeah I may be
wrong but my impression is that what
people are able to do very well is to is
to manage a limited amount of state in
course of traversing a document so
resolving backward pronoun references
and stuff like that this LS TM
architecture long short-term memory
architecture it can manage that kind of
limited sort of within passage kind of
state but if you ask it to manage
external state such as who did you give
a coffeemaker to last year it's a
different it's a different it's a
different deal and another thing is I
just alluded to it is there's a lot of
stress here on and it's a very active
area of research
you know meta learning would be one
aspect of this you know try to get it so
that systems don't require huge amount
of training to adjust it a new task and
again as I understand it the the high
level notion here is to identify some
sort of family of tasks and and do a
whole lot of training on instances
within that family and then and then
hope to find that that training
generalizes so that very little training
is needed to deal with the novel
instance the tasks and they're there do
seem there does need to be progress in
in that line but but but maybe not so
close to what would be involved in some
of the examples we're discussing here so
actually another piece of work at
Stanford that is I think responsive to
this I think is pretty interesting this
is huh there's a postdoc in NCS here and
so I just want to give kind of a sketch
of what they're up to so they're
developing a collaborative dialogue
agent so this this agent plays a kind of
a conversation game which goes like this
so there's it and then there's a human
interlocutor and and both players are
given a list of a short table with
information about maybe a dozen
individuals with different attributes
specified same attributes for both
players but but in different rounds of
the game maybe different attributes so
the attributes could include name where
somebody went to college notionally
dissolve course artificial where they
work whether they like being outdoors or
indoors and I don't know how
the attributes altogether but the table
maybe as shown here might have three of
these things and then descriptions say
maybe of a dozen individuals with these
different attributes and but then it's
contrived that on any trial there's
exactly one individual in common between
these two tables and the tables are
private so so if I'm if I'm playing the
machine I've got my table and I see
what's there but I don't see that the
table the machine has and vice versa and
then the task is for these people to
have a conversation which culminates in
them knowing what the common individual
is and reporters they're able to play
that pretty well but what I think is
interesting about it is the during the
degree of robustness that they're able
to secure here using a kind of a hybrid
scheme so the table that's provided
afresh each trial is you could say sort
of manually by which I mean not using
learning but there's a that maybe I
should just say procedurally transformed
into a knowledge graph which is kind of
what's shown there so that has you know
what are the entities and how are they
how are they related but then before any
of this happens there's been a training
process in which the system has been
exposed to that large number of examples
of actually human human dialogues and
what it's able to learn from that large
corpus of examples is a scheme that
allows it to to take a new utterance and
kind of decorate the knowledge graph
with information about which entities
are mentioned in the utterance that it's
processing and then it's also learned
how to take a decorated graph and
generate a representation of it this
graph embedding and then there's an
attentional scheme that that processes
that embedding and actually generates a
response and what I think is striking
here is that what what they've shown is
that they can train the system so that
it's able to function effectively if you
give it a completely novel table so
maybe this is a success of that kind of
meta learning framework so it's actually
able to do a good job of generating a
conversation about a a collection of
information that
you know it's it's a one at a very high
level like the other collections it's
had but in every specific respect it's
different so maybe this represents
progress it does represent progress I
think but but we can also see sort of
back on this point about you know what's
what would be involved to really deploy
something like this usefully if we
wanted to move it and I talked actually
with her about this so if we wanted to
move this to a significantly different
task so for instance we wanted to get it
so that the conversation involved
exchange of information so somebody
needs to be able to tell somebody some
new fact and have them retain it well
then it's it's it's sort of back to
square one you'd have to kind of train
that that thing again so and that's not
going to be workable in this sphere this
hope for sphere of human assistance but
nevertheless again I think this
represents maybe some some progress okay
so I mentioned this question of how
assistant could be offered and so
imagine that we we've sort of dealt with
these issues technically and now we're
going to deliver and there are a lot of
things so in the tech simplification
case sector there's work at it Lintz of
developing a sort of an architecture
that would allow somebody using a web
browser to deploy a wide range of tools
that you know as we're able to develop
them that would allow them to have text
rewritten in various ways so that's one
way that you could deliver some of this
stuff so another way I know if people
know about the IRS system so this has
been commercial for maybe a bit over a
year and it's today aimed at blind
people and the way it works is that if
you're a subscriber so it's a
subscription service if your subscriber
you have a pair of glasses with a
headset and a camera and no display
because you're blind and and this is
connected to a sort of super cell phone
and and you press a button on the phone
and you're put in spoke at speech
contact with a trained human agent
person shown there on the right and so I
heard a talk by a student is one of the
early users of this who was saying
you know as a blind person I want to
tell you that there's something you
probably have never thought about you
sighted people but I can tell you it's a
huge pain for me I come to class I need
to find a place to set okay and it's
really embarrassing because I kind of
have to Pat people down to find out that
there's somebody sitting there he says
it's great with IRA I press the button
and I say I need somewhere to sit and
they can see the room and they just tell
me where there's an empty seat and you
know problem problem solved so that's
just one instance I've been talking with
my self-advocate friends and and
actually with with IRA and there's
there's the prospect of creating a
version of IRA that would support people
with with cognitive limitations but
relevant of that to this talk is that
the ambition of IRA actually signaled by
the AI and the name is that whereas
today this is all done by trained human
agents the rest of it is they think the
core of about 75% of their transactions
could be automated so what they're
looking to do over time is to you know
gradually reduce what what human agents
would have to do so this is potentially
an attractive way of delivering
assistance the interest of time I'm
going to go quickly I won't actually
show you the in own voice thing but I'll
just kind of tell you what's going on
there so there's at least one study in
which they were offering certain kinds
of prompts to a person it was a brain
injury sufferer and what they did was to
record the prompts in the participants
own voice and deliver it in them in that
voice and and this may be responsive to
what I said before people really don't
like sort of dealing with other people
over things and and so perhaps
delivering things that in prisons own
voice as a way to really kind of help
with with the psychology of that but
then I want to get to this direct brain
connection actually I'm going to do a
little poll here so how many people
think actually let me before you get
doing the pawl let me let me make this
concrete okay so I ride my bike to work
every morning and I
do that by getting on my bike and riding
to work and I'm able to do that because
I know how to get here and actually I
know how to get here too but I so I had
a meeting down and in Menlo Park this
morning where I don't know how to get
there and so I was being guided by my
phone ok well what if instead of my
looking at my phone which is the third
party kind of a thing what if my phone
could be linked to my brain in such a
way that if I need to go to this place
at Menlo Park I know how to get there
ok in the same way that I know how to
get to work ok all right so this would
involve being able to inject content in
some way into my brain so the question
for you the polling question is how many
think that something like this will be
possible in five years ten twenty fifty
huh yeah that's right
but you know not the version I just
suggested anybody think it's never gonna
happen no it's interesting okay so we
all agree this is something to be
thinking about so maybe you know this
local startup and I'm I don't know these
people that I'm told they're respectable
so they're doing two things both of
which are really interesting so so when
is there they're developing non-invasive
optics based brain sensing and then the
upper part there they're imagining or
suggesting that they'll be able to track
the movement of a single action
potential pretty cool but even cooler
you'll notice that they're projecting
that they would be able to upload
information to the brain which is
basically the scenario that that I'm
talking about there so there's reason to
think that this might occur so three
simple and think about what it might
mean and you might think well that would
be really creepy but I talked with my
friend she of the prescriptions and the
and the gift list and she said that
would be great I would love it if it
worked out
I work that way I should I've talked
with Rob Rupert is a philosopher worries
about these things and we came up with a
view very speculative but suggest that
there's reason to think that this
wouldn't be creepy if it happened so
some of you may know the work of
Jonathan Haidt the morale psychologist
is actually a lot of popular writing
these days and he relates his framework
to that of David Hume and arguing that a
good way to think about the sort of
organization of the the human mental
machinery is that this little this this
little conscious rider up on top of this
great big elephant and that what happens
is really whatever the elephant does and
the job of the rider is actually not so
much to direct the elephant although it
has maybe limited ability to do that but
mostly it's to try to make sense out of
what the elephant is doing and and to
provide explanations and do diplomacy on
the elephant's behalf and that kind of
thing but the claim is that the rider
has very little insight into the
internals of the elephant in any way and
so if you buy into that kind of
framework and there is I'd say a good
deal of evidence for it then maybe if we
imagine that the rider somehow finds
that it's no longer on top of just the
elephant but somehow the elephant has
been supplemented by some kind of robot
well the the rider doesn't really know
anything about the elephant anyway you
know so what difference is gonna make so
in the scenario of my biking to Menlo
Park well I find that I can bike to
Menlo Park just as I found this morning
that or this afternoon that I could bike
over here it might not be so different
so it'll be interesting and I think most
of us feel this is going to happen on
some timescale and and maybe it'll
happen in a way that won't be actually
very disruptive and won't infringe
people's sense of autonomy and and the
like I'll just note so my colleague Brad
Hayes when he was at MIT and he's
continuing to do this work his interest
is human robot interaction and it turns
out there's an interesting parallel so
robot controllers are very complicated
now and and so the kind of classical
approach is to try to figure out what
they're doing involving like analyzing
their code
that kind of stuff and it just doesn't
work very well so what what Brad and
colleagues have developed is an approach
where there's sort of a second robot
whose job it is to watch the first one
and and and again try to interpret it's
its behavior and and make predictions
about it and provide explanations and
the like which is essentially the
architecture that hate is arguing all of
us have turning to risks here so this is
a actually a really terrific post from
Josh Lovejoy who's in the Google people
in AI research kind of grouping and time
to us prevent getting very much into
this and hoping maybe some of you've
heard at least of some instances of this
so maybe the best known example of a
whole fleet of things that Josh is
talking about here these people know
about these sentence guys sentencing
guidance automata so there was I don't
know if the business is still happening
I hope it's not but but there was a
company that offered machine learning or
or sort of big data based sentencing
guideline programs and so if you were a
judge you could enter the attributes of
the defendant into one of these things
and and get out a readout saying how to
what extent you should throw the book at
them well it turned out that based on
the data that we're there if you were a
black defendant you know nothing to do
with anything about you as an individual
you were gonna get the book thrown at
you why because that's what the data
seemed to show so Lovejoy's is calling
attention to that and many other
examples of this kind of thing
something's related that some of you may
know about the subpoena you banks of the
suny buffalo and her book automating
inequality the sort of situation that
you banks is pointing to is that
well-intentioned people with the aim of
improving the quality of and reducing
the cost of social services are
introducing various forms of automation
so basically replacing or maybe
augmenting a small cast of caseworkers
with you know algorithmic approaches and
and what this leads to
kind of example Eubanks documents is for
instance a person who was required by
guideline to maintain eligibility for
certain benefits to to come to an
appointment with somebody and missed the
appointment and had their benefit cut
off while they missed the appointment
because they were in the hospital and a
human a human caseworker could kind of
understand a situation like that and
respond to it but the algorithm this
person was dealing with didn't and you
might say what does this have to do with
disability what kind of two things so
one is I mean this is about the poor as
you see but the overlap of the poor and
people with disabilities is very
substantial the other thing is some of
you might know this there's no such
thing in u.s. disability law or policy
as a permanent disability okay even
though there of course are permanent
disability so I have a friend who has a
permanent disability so every couple of
years he has to requalified for his
benefits okay so he has to again
document that that you know he can't
walk okay even though everybody would
agree that his condition is such that
he's never gonna be able to walk
nevertheless he has to yes to do this so
people with disabilities do find
themselves dealing with with these kinds
of bureaucratic agencies so I think we
need to ask whether or in what way
people with cognitive disabilities may
need to be concerned about the
projection of machine learning sort of
data driven data analytics driven kinds
of technologies into their world in this
way so that's the end so again I return
to my question I'd love help from any of
you in understanding these things and
what the sort of just a small part of
the sort of word salad up there there
are a lot of developments so try to get
an overview of what's happening some of
you may know well boy this this great
technology that's going to do exactly
what you're interested in and it's
acronym is the following I'd love to
have that there's my contact information
and mention one other things so the the
tiny URL there is if if people are by
any chance interested in participating
in a code sprint it's not exactly on
this stuff but it's related so
I'm visiting a social good nonprofit
called benetech which works on inclusive
learning and so we're gonna be doing a
code sprint in Sunnyvale
to get people together to do some
brainstorming and prototyping of things
that might be done for example to help
struggling math learners would be one of
the foci so some of you might be
interested in that or know people who
are please get in touch so that's all
from that's all from me so thanks very
much for your attention and let me take
questions comments and suggestions thank
you yeah okay I think it's Parkinson's
that they're bringing implants of some
buzz word like that that they're they're
putting probes way down in there and
feeding stuff in that makes people yeah
yeah that's right I'm I don't know where
you were in your actually what was your
vote when do you think will see brain
upload how far out you gonna be dead
it's gonna be in your lifetime fine
friend upload yeah well so knowing how
to get to Menlo Park or the the
Starbucks at 14.1 willow Menlo Park
knowing how to get there you shaking
your head yeah okay but let me know
actually I'm curious anybody here done
any direct current brain stimulation
transcranial brain stimulation
okay so huh
tens units so you have done some no no
through your through your head have you
done that one somebody done the one
through your head so with a 9-volt
battery and a 50 cent current regulator
you can do this I haven't done it
okay so so there's a guy named Frank
Palermo this is a interesting guy
happens to be based in Boulder and I
think he became very wealthy developing
a really powerful rehab technique
involving electrical muscle stimulation
so he came to talk to me about something
and he asked me about this which I knew
nothing about which I still know hardly
anything about so he described it so you
know you put electrodes on your head and
you and and you put a little bit of
current into some some part of your
brain and well okay okay so yeah let me
that's where the current the current
regulator comes in I guess okay great so
so Frank is is describing this and I'm
describing the various risks that it
seemed obvious or involved and and and
and I'm also thinking well can this be
legal or whatever and Frank said well
you know NIH has been really interested
in this but the more they've studied the
potential risks of doing this the more
they found actually that there aren't
any risks but there are benefits so
Frank himself said that doing this he
became much smarter so the way he
described the phenomenon way so I don't
know if anybody's been on riddle and
they're taking somebody else's Ritalin
people do that and and when they do they
started ascribe gee I can focus much
better and all all that kind of thing
and that's how coming that's how Frank
described this so I asked the obvious
question so I said if you continued
doing and he said no and I said why not
and he said I didn't like the person I
became but but nevertheless there's
there's apparently something real there
were you going to comment on this
wedding-day college graduation and he
memorized their base to four states but
his mother told me how to forget that
problem was is remembers like too much
yeah my father was a builder he gave two
catalogues of doors and within like
about two weeks he had memorized out
through the catalogs he knew every kind
of our existence problems and you
probably could read it a DMV booklet and
a car manual yeah think about like
problem with putting something into your
brain and all you would be able to
remember was how to get to that one
place yeah and indeed a lot too you
can't just you know simply erase yeah
you know forgetting yeah yeah yeah lots
of lots of things to lots of things to
to to worry about yeah that's what you
know what you're saying about your your
friend reminds me something else was
illustrated in the conversation this
morning and people may know about this
so there's there's there's a lot of
reform being attempted in the education
space which which broadly takes the form
of recognizing extreme human diversity
and working with it instead of as is so
often the case the educational system
you know trying to sort of discipline
everybody and and some of the some of
the results of doing that are really
extraordinary so if you put people in a
situation where they're able to to do
the things that they're they're able to
do as opposed to spending all their time
try to do things they can't you know
sometimes the results are remarkable so
I was hearing from actually person a
marina of Yzerman who actually does some
work with the ed school here and and as
a school in in Menlo Park so she was
telling me that the first two
non-speaking students have now been
admitted to the UC system
so these are people who communicate
using what's called a symbol board where
they're they're pointing to characters
on a board and working with a sort of
transcription as to can do that and if
you ask the obvious question you know
why are you saying a keyboard or a
touchscreen it's the answer that is not
very clear but the answer is that they
can't do that why they can't do it is
unclear but what they can do is use like
a paper board and the suggestion it has
something to do with the details of the
motor interaction so marina was
speculating there's something about
being able to position something in a
precise way in your sort of body
coordinate system and sort of rigid
things like tablets and stuff like that
just don't allow people to do that sorry
who yeah yeah that's right
so Hawking was doing it because there
wasn't an alternative and then he
switched to the tech but these are
people for whom all the ordinary
all-trans which work great for a lot of
people you know just don't work so again
the message is people's abilities are
extraordinarily quirky but if if you're
able to work with them the results can
sometimes be remarkable other other
thoughts about some people brain is just
wired so they can't yeah press it back
knows yeah yeah yeah yeah so I can't
research that triggers something else so
maybe people know about this and I try
to have to dredge up the reference so if
you're interested if you send me an
email or doing so I'm not able to dredge
it up from my from my brain but but
there's there's good reason to think
among vision scientists that we have on
the order of six visual systems they
share the same light sensing apparatus
but
beyond that they're actually
dissociative all so there was a dramatic
case of someone who suffered carbon
monoxide poisoning which sort of
randomly knocks out some portion of the
brain and and after this experience the
person believed herself to be blind and
was believed by everybody to be blind
and right there you might think well
this is crazy how could someone you know
either blind or not how could you
believe yourself to be blind okay so
this person who believed herself to be
blind and was believed by others to be
blind
happily started working with a
psychology research group and and one of
the things that happened was that the
group went out for a picnic in the
nearby forest and and and then somebody
noticed that this blind person was able
to follow the group along this rutted
trail with roots and rocks and
everything flawlessly
so to kind of cut to the chase the
visual system the Porsche or that the
aspect of the visual system that guided
motor movement for this person was
intact but the portion of the system
that gives rise to our familiar
phenomenal sense of seeing things was
not working so so the person had no
conscious awareness of of what was going
on and and they developed a procedure to
kind of probe this which which went like
this so they set up a table with a a
slot mounted on a sort of a gimbal so
that it could be turned so the slot
could be given any orientation the
person sitting on the other side of the
table and this is given a card and
they're asked what's the orientation of
the slot and they'd say you know I have
no idea I can't see the slot put the
card in the slot okay and and they did
video recording to establish that they
had oriented it correctly well before it
reached the vicinity of the slot and
then eventually she acquired the ability
to actually say what the orientation was
in the way she did that was she would
pretend she had a card in her hand and
that she was going to be putting it into
the slot and then she would observe the
orientation of her hand so that's
actually thought of this before but
that's kind of an example of this
elephant idea okay so so the elephant
knew how to orient the card the rider
could acquire knowledge of the
orientation from noticing what the
elephant was doing but the visual
experience at all no you can't see yes
he could you said actually here if the
light is on there one of many translate
I'm curious here from the students any
you're gonna work on any of this stuff
like brain implant sir it's happening
here you could do it what are you gonna
do instead
okay yeah they serve coffee and cookies
afterwards and after that big great so
if I google that will I find easy to
find out her stanford.edu
events cool great that's going to say
that they some kind of bio electrical
engineer people have asked me to build
these brain implants and stimulate yeah
the most is people that use them they
don't have a clue what's gonna be the
result of what they're doing at all and
tell you about briefly is 25 years ago
scientists they put air bubbles
underneath in the brain and just put a
pressure OH
uh-huh and they did it to about 334
patients about 10 percent of them yeah
about two weeks later that bubble head
resore yeah and they lost the ability
about 10% of those 334 patients became
some kind of savant really and different
types of unintended consequence totally
unintended once again these people don't
have a clue what they were doing so the
options near putting pressure on the
brain so if i if i google air bubbles on
the brain will i find out about that
come on if somebody read it up it's
probably out there somewhere yeah that
there may be other people interested in
enhancing cognitive abilities
particularly in the military may be
doing similar kinds of research to yours
but may have less altruistic goals I'm
interested in your exposure to that boy
that's interesting so I don't really
have any and of course that means
nothing about whether it's I figure I
will say that
so I entered briefly working as an
adviser to Charlie naked lakyn at the at
the National Institute for disability
and rehabilitation research and we were
seeking federal partners this neither
neighbor has enough money and so we had
some interesting discussions with I ARPA
the Intelligence Advanced Research
Projects Agency and they were actually
quite keen on working with us because
they they at the time probably all the
time they could use good press and and
there were a number of technologies they
working on not so much pertinent to this
but they do a lot of stuff in language
and speech processing that could be
quite useful
let's but so far we haven't quite
secured crossover but but you're right I
mean there are lots of reasons people
are interested in this kind of thing
other than rather than this yeah but I
try should I should try to find
something out about that price ring so
they like one of my short-term memory
that's why that's why I mentioned this
this dreck transcranial direct current
brain stimulation and I fear that I was
sort of to flip in describing it and I'm
gonna continue that a little bit if you
go on YouTube you can find some pretty
funny stuff of the forum you know some
something young person forgive me is is
very excited you know as I took such a
such standardized test and I stimulated
myself here and my scoring up 10 points
and but you know then I got this kind of
buzz you know so I moved them over here
and I took it again and I got 15 but but
so again I'm undermining my own case but
apparently there is a
the serious finding that this kind of
stuff does things and maybe it's you
know in a way to me it's similar to the
thing about the air bubbles as far as I
can tell there's no rational reason any
of this should do anything in particular
and maybe it doesn't maybe its effects
are pretty random but it does seem clear
that it does things that's of course
that goes back to BC yeah a little bit
so the Coleman Institute has conferences
and temples been been a speaker in that
in that setting and actually I mention
there that you know I thought ISM is
actually it's very big around here
demographically and and sort of
politically and otherwise and very
contentious area but but one where the
the self-advocates are many of them you
know extremely outspoken the society are
really accommodating people and and and
not trying to push people to be some way
because you think that's how they ought
to be but instead to go with how they
want to be is is is is really is really
important you know temple as far as I
know kind of escaped a lot of that but
there's this there's some pretty
horrendous stuff you can read out there
from adult people with autism about how
they were treated as children but again
the theme I think the the progressive
theme here is is really working with
people and and their differences yeah
well if you drive an email for some
reason this is this the first author is
it's just one of those names that
doesn't stay in my hand okay so that's a
longer list every year but but if you
send me an email I know I can find it
but briefly I'm not gonna be able to
count up to six but there's the
phenomenal awareness one there's the
motor control one the one that guides
your feet and then as was mentioned
there's there's face but I try to know
the latest science there so I guess it's
not literally faces but but maybe that's
the main use of it but anyway there's a
there's some sort of special geometry
engine and to say a little bit more
about that you know when we look at the
world here you know we have the illusion
of living in a kind of homogeneous
geometric space you know so there's the
geometry of this chair there's the
geometry of your face and and they don't
look different it's not like your face
lights up somehow but there's a lot of
evidence that my perception of your face
is completely different from the
perception of the chair it's somehow all
woven into this deceptively uniform
space so there are three of them but
apparently there are a few others I
don't know what they are
I haven't heard him speak for a long
time or face sideways a switch very I
think this so fits in with the hey you
know elephant idea that you know there's
every reason to think there's lots of
complicated stuff like that going on and
we're uh turley unaware of it you know
it plays no role and
how we experience the world or no direct
role in how we alright well thanks
everybody
you